yeah I saw it that's right I'm a man
that's what I do
Magic Mike stars Channing Tatum Alex pay
for Matthew McConaughey it's directed by
Steven Soderbergh okay now he's one of
my favorite directors he said can i
director who can take a really cliched
story and just turn it upside down and
make you look at it differently this
movies about a male stripper played by
Channing Tatum and he wants to go places
in his life you know he doesn't want to
just continuously be in this lifestyle
for the rest of his days he wants to do
things with his life he has plans
aspirations and dreams now when you
watch the trailers of this movie okay I
pretty much the last thing I want to do
is stare at a bunch of man ass for about
two hours and that's just not my idea of
fun that being said I actually really
enjoyed this movie and that is really
saying a lot for Steven Soderbergh's
direction and for the actual direction
this movie was going in because when you
watch the trailers of this movie they're
very misleading I figured that going in
because Steven Soderbergh's movies are
always way more artsy than the trailers
lead on see when I watch the trailer for
this movie I actually was doing there
like know if I can watch this I because
in my head I was thinking it was just
gonna be like two hours of this instead
it was more like this
so the people who go into this movie
wanting to see most of the dancing and
that's really all they want to see
they're going to get a lot of that but
it's not so in-your-face and it's not
exploitive it's not like guilty pleasure
like the movies showgirls the point of
this movie is it shows what a guy in
that lifestyle deals with the perception
of a man like that from other people and
how that affects him and how he really
wants to do other things with his life
too but he has that kind of as a barrier
because that's the only way he can make
enough money to do what he really wants
to do so this movie is actually a fun
drama with really compelling characters
good acting good writing an excellent
direction and yes there are a lot of
sequences with dancing and everything
with the guys but it's not like so
disgusting for a straight guy like me to
be able to experience that because it
shows the guys preparing for it it shows
them afterwards and it really gets you
an idea of what some of these guys go
through every day but what really makes
this movie work is the direction and
Channing Tatum's performance they both
work hand in hand very well and Tatum is
really improving he's consistently
getting better in the movies I've seen
him in Matthew McConaughey is terrific
in this movie he is very entertaining
you know half of what he says is just
alright alright alright he has this
great line in the trailer I've been
repeating it back and forth the past
couple days because it's so hilarious
the law says that you cannot touch but I
think I see a lot of lawbreakers up in
here it's such a funny line obviously
the larger audience for this movie is
more than likely going to be women
that's understandable I spoke with a lot
of them after the screening and to be
honest a lot of them were actually
disappointed and pretty much all the
guys I spoke to liked it isn't that
weird but it's true this movie actually
has a very strong sense of understanding
men this movie deals a lot with the
female perspective of men and how a lot
of women sometimes view men especially
men who are in the position that these
guys are in and if you're actually
really compelling all the different
conversations these characters get into
but there's actually a lot of stuff that
a guy could really do in this movie I
was really surprised genuinely some of
the issues I have the movie are the
pacing it does get a little slow toward
the third act some of the character
motivations are a little unclear in the
finale of the film certain characters
kind of just fade away and you're like
that seemed unfinished sometimes the
movie benefits from that sometimes
unnecessary to have like a concrete boom
ending with the character but there are
certain things happen in the movie I
would have liked a little more resolve
you know to happen but for the most part
Magic Mike is actually a really
entertaining movie shot very well good
performances and I really enjoyed it I'm
going to get Magic Mike a B+ so I'd like
to know what's the movie that you were a
little apprehensive about going into the
theater at first scene because you're
like I don't know about this this just I
don't think I can do this and then you
actually ended up really enjoying it and
you were surprised comment below let me
know guys thanks for watching and as
always if you liked this review can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes